hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning iot full course but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session first we will begin with
a quick crash course on iot where we
will learn what exactly is iot and the
fundamental concepts of internet of
things followed by the crash course on
iot we will learn what is arduino once
we understand what exactly is arduino we
will dive into the raspberry pi once we
are done with the fundamentals and
technical concepts of arduino and
raspberry pi we will discuss the
critical differences between the both
so once having a better understanding of
what are raspberry pi and or renault and
their critical differences between each
of them we will try to develop some
projects based on both arduino and
raspberry pi once we have the best
understanding of arduino and raspberry
pi we will dive deep into raspberry pi
zero once we are done with the raspberry
pi zero we will dive into the latest
version of raspberry pi that is
raspberry pi 4. so these are the agenda
pointers that we will be discussing
today hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now over to our training experts
until recently access to the internet
was limited via devices like the desktop
tablet or smartphone
but now with the internet of things aka
iot practically all appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely
it is a system of interconnected devices
that transfer data
over a wireless network without any
human intervention
so hey everyone in this video we help
you understand what iot is and how it is
impacting our day-to-day life
we will also understand the iot
architecture and look at the new
trending iot projects for 2021
but before that if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
i'm sure you're excited to learn so
let's dive right in
imagine you're at work and realize that
you might not have turned off the air
conditioner while leaving your house
instead of traveling all the way back
home what if you could use your
smartphone to know the status of your ac
and perhaps even turn it off
wouldn't that be amazing
well yes
and this can be achieved with the help
of the internet of things
until recently access to the internet
was limited via devices like the desktop
tablet or smartphone but now with iot
practically all appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely iot is shaping the way we live
our lives it helps us get a better
insight into the working of things
around us
so what exactly is the internet of
things
iot is a system of interrelated devices
connected to the internet to transfer
and receive data from one to the other a
smart home is the best example of iot
home appliances like the ac doorbell
thermostats smoke detectors water
heaters and security alarms can be
interconnected to share data with the
user over a mobile application
the user can now get detailed insight
into the working of the devices around
him
think about it until recently the
internet helped people connect and
interact with each other but now
inanimate objects or things have the
ability to sense the surroundings to
interact and collaborate with one
another
for example
in the morning when your alarm goes off
the iot system can open the window
blinds turn on the coffee pot for you
and even turn on the water heater
although all of this is fascinating
there's a lot that goes on in the
background to ensure seamless
functioning from effective communication
between devices to accurate processing
of the data received a lot of components
are involved
in the context of iot devices hardware
can be classified into general devices
and sensing devices the general devices
are the main components of the data hub
and information exchange
they are connected either by wired or
wireless interfaces
home appliances are a classic example of
such devices
the sensing devices on the other hand
include sensors and actuators they
measure the temperature humidity light
intensity and other parameters
these iot devices are connected to the
network with the help of gateways
these gateways or processing nodes
process the information collected from
the sensors and transfer it to the cloud
the cloud acts as both the storage and
processing unit actions are performed on
the collected data for further learning
and inferences
wired and wireless interfaces like wi-fi
bluetooth zigbee gsms and so on are used
to provide connectivity to ensure its
ubiquity applications need to support a
diverse set of devices and communication
protocols from tiny sensors capable of
sensing and reporting the desired factor
to powerful back-end servers that are
utilized for data analysis and knowledge
extraction
to help you understand it's working
let's take a simple scenario let's
suppose you want to water your garden
every time the moisture level in the
soil drops
instead of doing it manually you could
automate it using iot
the sensors and actuators installed
gauge the soil for its moisture this
information is sent to the iot gateway
with the help of communication protocols
like mqtt or http the gateway
significantly aggregates data and feeds
it to the cloud with the help of wi-fi
lan
once the moisture level drops the system
is immediately triggered and the
sprinklers are turned on however with
the information stored in the cloud a
detailed analysis like the time of the
day the sprinkler was turned on the rate
at which the moisture in the soil
reduces and so on can be done and the
report could be sent over to you on your
smartphone over an app
with the improved response monitoring
and analytical capabilities iot is being
adopted in almost all industries and
domains opening doors to endless
applications
today iot is being used extensively to
lessen the burden on humans to name a
few iot is deployed for smart homes
wearables watches and bracelets smart
cars
smart farming smart retail smart grids
smart city and smart healthcare
with such a wide spectrum of
applications the future of it looks more
promising than ever before in 2018 there
were about 23 billion connected devices
which was more than double the world
population
according to experts there will be over
80 billion devices by 2025. iot is a
vision to connect all devices with the
power of the internet always learning
and always growing now that you have a
picture of what iot is here's a simple
question for you
which of the following technologies is
not used as an interface for a network
1. wi-fi
2. ethernet
3.
zigbee
four
vpn
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below three lucky
winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
the integration of iot with other
technologies like cloud computing
machine learning and artificial
intelligence is paving the way for many
new and exciting innovations
and that is the internet of things for
you in short
the first wave of the internet
revolution came in with the growth of
personal computers and in the second
wave the internet came right onto our
palms that is with the advent of mobile
devices and here we are living the third
wave where all electronic devices are
almost already connected to the internet
or will be in the near future
yes the internet of things will bring
about the next industrial revolution and
will drastically transform the way we
live and experience technology today
quite possibly the internet of things
will be as disruptive as the internet
itself particularly when combined with
big data and predictive analytics
but what exactly is iot the concept
behind iot is about connecting just
about everything to the internet in real
time which directly improves our quality
of life and experiences
for instance how are you watching this
video right now on a pc a mobile or a
tablet well whichever device you're
using is definitely connected to the
internet and that means you're already
using an iot device
sensors are becoming the endpoints of
iot networks wondering what exactly a
sensor is these sensors collect an
increasing amount of context aware data
and information such as location images
weather conditions and inject them into
networks actuators and applications in
real time
big data analytics and predictions have
become apparent synonymous helping
perform and execute tasks seamlessly
with minimal to zero errors
are you ready to admit a major
breakthrough
life in the present is great but the
future looks like it could be way more
exciting how we may ask
since there are billions of physical
devices around the world that are now
connected to the internet collecting and
sharing data in real time terabytes of
data are going to become better bytes
which represents thousand terabytes each
there is going to be a shift from
wideband networks to narrowband networks
for better range
and you'll also soon witness the
communication system transcend from 4g
to 5g wireless communications
[Music]
iot will definitely be the paradigm
shift of effective multitasking with
massive applications
now let's have a look at the future with
iot environment imagine you're driving
your smart car to work and you're quite
late don't you worry because your car
can now provide the shortest route with
less congestion
not only that the integrated sensors in
the car alerts you about mechanical
assistance you also have the access to
automatic temperature control and not to
forget in case you're tired or wary the
car becomes self-driven since it comes
with an accident prevention system
as you are driving you see the smart
farms through your window farmers are
happier thanks to iot which helped them
with better heat and provided more
efficiency than ever
you might wonder how with the help of
systems like autonomous self-driving
tractors adaptive irrigation systems
soil health monitoring and animal
welfare monitoring systems this is
possible
you also see smart factories which use
iiot that is industrial internet of
things with the help of analytics and
automation systems iiot helps in
tracking goods in real time inventory
management automated delivery system and
much more
now you're returning home from office
your car can park itself automatically
your fingerprint voice or even your
smartphone is enough to control all home
appliances from lights to television and
your door to water taps too are you
excited to experience this smart future
which is not far away of course you
should be
the applications of iot will be seen in
every industry across sectors beat
education healthcare manufacturing
automotive you name it iot is definitely
going to have a role to play in each one
of them
possibly the fourth way will be the
internet of everything or ioe
which would encompass all physical
things processes data and people through
wearables and surgically implanted
sensors unlike iot which focuses only on
physical devices change is the only
constant and the world will never be the
same with the growth of ubiquitous
connectivity and iot is sure to change
the way billions of people live their
lives today the wide internet of things
as a learner you should learn iot as it
provides better scope for future data
scientists as well as provides for
promising career opportunities
you can also build and manage your own
iot for your home as a company executive
you should learn iot because it will
help you measure everything in the
business you also get real-time metrics
actionable data and better connectivity
across industries
after completing this course you should
be able to explain the concept of
internet of things comprehensive
describe hardware software and other
connectivity building blocks of iot
describe design considerations
pertaining architecture
framework and interoperability
explain the security considerations with
iot pertain to vulnerabilities
explain industry 4.0 internet to
everything and social iot
and finally describe iot framework in
enterprises
in the context of iot devices hardware
can be divided into two categories
general devices and sensing devices
the general devices do the embedded
processing and connectivity for the
platforms they are connected either by
wired network or wireless interfaces
they are the main component for data
collection and information processing
the current home appliances are classic
example of such devices that are
controlled by a sensor
these sensors help solve common problems
apart from sensors actuators are another
important device in iot that perform
similar functions with different
capabilities they work as interface
between sensors and machines and collect
various information like humidity and
light intensity
this information is computed using the
edge layer which typically sits between
the cloud and the sensor they are the
layers that store the intermittent
transfer of information
finally the backend server of the cloud
processes this information
both the sensors and actuators are the
chief components of iot the sensors
measure temperature humidity light
intensity and other key parameters of
home environment
the second most crucial aspect of iot is
device management platforms or dmps
the dmvs as they are shortly called are
the platforms through which these assets
interact with the software layer through
network gateways dmps come with various
functionalities which include firmware
upgrades security patching and reporting
of metrics they also help develop alert
mechanism with industrial equipment with
more open source os like arduino overall
it is an important aspect of the
management of the device penetration
connectivity blocks connectivity blocks
collectively is considered as the
backbone of an iot setup
there are various connectivity layers
like usb can protocols and modbus
the next generation protocols of wi-fi
are lora and zigbee they can interface
with any application or modules a small
device embedded in an object
the entire landscape is called gateway
architecture
various ports are
232.485 from usb that come with gateway
architecture
the device interface is important for
the data transfer and enables digital
transformation with third-party
applications and systems
communication protocols and standards
let us try to understand the various
communication protocols available to set
up an iot
the first is the satellite this enables
the cell phone communication through an
antenna situated within 10 to 15 miles
they have a stable and universal
connection
the second is the protocol is the wi-fi
and is based on five gigahertz
frequencies
it provides internet access within a
certain range and are an affordable
option
it has well protected protocols
the third is the radio frequency
it is the easiest form of communication
a few examples are zigbee and z-wave
which use low-power rf radio
it consumes low energy which is very
advantageous
is relatively simple to configure
the fourth in this list is rfid it uses
wireless electromagnetic fields to
identify sensors and objects
good thing about it is that it does not
require power
the fifth is bluetooth which is useful
for short term and short distance data
exchange it is present in every
smartphone and has sensors
the final one is near field
communication or nfc it uses
electromagnetic induction and loop
antennas
it comes with encryption has low speed
communication and is used for short
range data exchange future of iot
connectivity
iot connectivity is the future the
launch of new technologies like 5g
the 5g with low latency and higher
throughput will increase the penetration
of iot
5g cellular technology is supported by
the network for virtualization
even for the common use case such as for
t vendor real-time predictive analytics
can be available
so
overall the delivery time is reduced
with iot
5g and iot are embedded technologies
both can be sliced and diced for
predictive analytics and real-time
business decisions
5g will help devices connect through a
network with high-speed bandwidth
iot device architecture
there are four layers in the device
architecture
the base layer consists of iot devices
this includes all the components like
sensors with the ability to sense
compute and connect other devices let's
move on to the second layer which is the
iot gateway or aggregation layer this
layer significantly aggregates data from
various sensors these two layers form
the definition engine and they set the
rules for data aggregation next layer is
based on cloud it's called processing
engine or event processing layer it has
numerous algorithms and data processing
elements that are ultimately displayed
on a dashboard
this layer basically processes the data
obtained from the sensor layer the last
layer is called the application layer or
api management layer
it acts as an interface between
third-party application and
infrastructure the entire landscape is
supported by device managers and
identity and access managers
which are useful for security of the
architecture
many individuals and organizations have
contributed to create and set this
standard it covers the entire network
and endpoint systems it brings a
structural approach with security
controls in place it provides a
demarcation based on its uses for
enterprise to build iot products this
standard has 85 detailed recommendations
and a structured approach that can fit
into any iot ecosystem it has a flexible
framework addressing the diversity of
the technology aligned to the regulation
it also has risk modeling capabilities
for any organization to choose from
including endpoint ecosystems the
standard is flare reflexible and comes
with the inbuilt risk assessments for
any organization to adapt overall it is
an interesting standard and easy to get
trained at
iot security best practices
there are many best practices in iot
security let's look at some best
practices pertaining to iot hardware
first of all the hardware should be
tamper-proof they should have undergone
dynamic testing with specific data
protection algorithms and should be
updated on firmware and patches
the network components must be authentic
with encryption kernel controls and
division of networks into segments other
security measures include privacy
protection for sensitive information and
other regulations like safe harbor
statements
there are many value drivers to help the
internet of everything key drivers are
employee productivity
supply and logistics
customer experiences
innovation and time to market asset
utilization all the factors are tightly
linked to generate new revenue gains for
any enterprise
time to market and innovation
this will help with the competitive
index
of the organization
he'll help discover mvp to reduce the
cost of building and bring improvement
in customer experience asset utilization
is the form of digital physical and even
smart assets the asset discovery is the
requirement for the establishment of the
iot ecosystem supply chain is also a key
value driver and assesses the
requirement of internet of everything
in addition to the drivers there are
significant elements
the elements stand in four buckets the
first is data which encapsulates sending
and analyzing data
the second bucket is the people
who are always connected and have
contextual subject mapping with the
real-time world for decision making
the third bucket is the things which
link people to machine with endpoints
ipi addresses and sensors
the last bucket is machined to data
which talks with a business value and
action iteration
essentially building simple models to
achieve corporate results
internet of everything growth engine the
internet of everything comes with a
growth engine for any organization it
includes people or the most valuable
resources
the process of making the right effort
the things that includes the physical
devices other objects and the data taken
from sensors to make actionable insights
for decision making is important
people
process
things
and data are the growth engine elements
it gives the company an edge in the
digital transformation world
with data privacy and transparency
mechanism it is important for every
organization to follow internet ethics
and compliance
iot and fleet management
let's discuss some use cases of iot
the fleet management is a classic
example of iot in application in this
domain iot is mainly used to track
vehicles from one point to another
using iot technology the entire fleet
can be monitored with a support of rfid
chips embedded within every car in the
fleet the same rfid can also be used to
track products such as consumer goods
electronics and food items
you can get real-time information on the
routes that the fleet takes
there are obd devices that can be used
to track vehicles behavior and
performance including fuel consumption
and mileage
this can reduce the total cost and
provide greater return on investment
according to a recent study the iot
market will increase to 8.28 billion
dollars by 2021 sensor's linked
artificial intelligence help the bankers
track all the activities in the back end
the advancements of mobile phones and
digital assistants along with 5g
connectivity makes customer experience
seamless first and foremost it is data
data is the new oil financial
institutions have structured and
unstructured data of the customers
they can slice and dice the data for
profiling segmentation product launches
and digital services enablement
the data can create a large economic
drive and give rise to new business
models like nfc banking digital
assistance banking and social media
banking
with this transformation internet of
things provides competitive advantage to
the banking insurance and financial
services
while the end goal remains to help
customers save money and give a bundle
offer
let's understand how iot revolutionizes
various industries
with the advent of the internet of
things there are many industries
experiencing digital transformation such
as financial services healthcare
manufacturing communications energy
retail and transportation
iot has initiated changes at all levels
user infrastructure and large-scale
applications analytics with real-time
dashboard and iot support allows
informed decision making for businesses
this also means that iot is introducing
a new revenue model for enterprises
around the world
learning objectives by the end of this
lesson you will be able to
explain the iot architecture and
frameworks describe the iot
interoperability and its design
considerations and discuss
industry-aligned use cases
iot device architecture
there are four layers in the device
architecture the base layer consists of
iot devices
this includes all the components like
sensors with the ability to sense
compute and connect other devices
let's move on to the second layer which
is the iot gateway or aggregation layer
this layer significantly aggregates data
from various sensors these two layers
form the definition engine and to set
the rules for data aggregation next
layer is based on cloud is called
processing engine or event processing
layer it has numerous algorithms and
data processing elements that are
ultimately displayed on a dashboard
this layer basically processes the data
obtained from the sensor layer the last
layer is called the application layer or
api management layer it acts as an
interface between third-party
application and infrastructure the
entire landscape is supported by device
managers and identity and access
managers
which are useful for security of the
architecture
iot reference architecture next let's
learn about the various layers in iot
reference architecture device layer
the device layer is the main component
where there are various devices like
sensors that are interconnected some
examples are bluetooth connected via
mobile phone and zigbee via zigbee
gateway the other devices include the
raspberry pi that's connected to the
ethernet via wi-fi this is directly
connected to the communication layers
which are part of the second layer
communication layer the communication
layer or gateway layer has
rest protocols
and other application level protocols
both layers are tightly coupled and
generate enormous amount of data
now the bus layer or aggregation layer
acts as a message broker it forms a
bridge between the data and the
communication layer for the sensors
this is an important layer for three
reasons
it supports an http server and or a mqtt
broker
it aggregates and combines
communications via gateway
and it bridges and transforms data
between different protocols
the next layer is the event processing
analytics layer which drives data and
provides transformation to the data
generated
it provides the ability to do event
processing the data is stored in the
database
the client layer is used to create a
web-based engine to interact with
external apis
this can be fed into the api management
systems this layer helps create a
dashboard and provides a view of
analytics and event processing
this layer helps communicate with
systems outside the network using
machine and machine communication
so we've seen the comprehensive iot
reference architecture with various
components rule engines interfaces and
security systems embedded
cross-functional architecture is
possible using device manager that
provides a single platform for remote
management the device manager
communicates with devices through set
protocols
device management uses device management
agents and is responsible for the remote
management of software
the identity layer has the capabilities
of cyber security including policy
control and oauth 2 token instruments
other capabilities include identity
services
xacml pdp and directory of users eg
ldap iot reference frameworks there are
a lot of frameworks for iot setup but
the most common is iso
30141 and it provides commonly used
vocabulary
reusable designs and best practices for
any developer to design an application
it also has many secure application
standards that derive the maximum
benefit for the organization and reduce
the risks
iot standardization and design
considerations
there are a number of iot standards
and these are evolving over time some of
the key ones are m2m that is a machine
to machine service layer that can be
embedded in hardware and software to
connect devices
contiki which is an open source
operating system for low-cost low-power
iot microcontrollers
light os a unix-like operating system
for wireless sensor networks
random phase multiple access
this is a proprietary standard for
connecting iot objects
the last one is sig fox a proprietary
low power low throughput technology for
iot and m2m communications
iot interoperability challenges
iot maturity comes with several
challenges specifically pertaining to
interoperability and interfacing the
reasons are coexistence of multifarious
systems
devices sensors equipment etc that
interchange location time dependent
information in varied data formats
languages data models constructs data
quality and complex interrelationships
multivision
system designed by manufacturers over
time for varied application domains
making formulation of global agreements
and commonly accepted specifications
very difficult
new things that get introduced and that
support a new unanticipated structures
and protocols existence of low power
devices which need to exchange data over
lossy networks and may have minimal
likelihood or accessibility for a power
recharge in months or years
iot design considerations when you
choose an iot solution you need to
consider several factors
like its wireless capability
functionality interoperability secure
storage
immediate boot capacity device
categorization
bandwidth cryptographic control and
power management the design
considerations should be a mix of the
estimated average of all these
components and index to balance the user
requirements you also need to set up a
dispute resolution mechanism in case of
failure in the long run
iot device architecture network and
cloud there are four stages of
integrating the different iot processes
stage one network things wireless
sensors and actuators stage 2 sensor
data aggregation systems and analog to
digital data conversion
stage 3 the appearance of edge id
systems
stage 4 analysis management and storage
of data as these stages are evolving the
devices the network and the cloud
application must be leveled equally in
ecosystem for better stability and
security the iot architecture is a
combination of things devices platform
and sensors with data stage one of an
iot architecture consists of networked
things typically wireless sensors and
actuators stage 2 has internet gateways
and data acquisition systems that
includes sensor data aggregation systems
and analog to digital conversion in
stage three edge its systems perform
pre-processing of the data before it
moves to the data center or cloud
finally in stage four data center and
cloud is where the data is analyzed
managed and stored on traditional
back-end data center systems
fundamentally we need to have a
functional scalable available and
maintainable architecture if these are
not supported then architecture is not
useful now let's look at the three
architecture areas of iot one the client
side iot device layer two operators on
the server side iot gateway layer
and three a pathway for connecting
clients and operators iot platform layer
these three layers interface with each
other on a data synchronization front
and pathway to generate more data from
various applications the feasibility of
the layers depends on their application
let's now differentiate between
centralized and decentralized iot
architectures the centralized
architecture is a hub and is managed
from one point whereas the decentralized
one is based on the use case
they do not help in industrial iot
solution the centralized architecture is
associated with cloud architectures in
which a central hub provides a series of
backend services to smart devices in
decentralized architecture there are
many scenarios that require autonomous
communication between smart devices and
an iot topology without the need of
essential hub the centralized systems
help in event processing and whereas
decentralized systems operate more of
peer-to-peer messaging the decentralized
auditing is one of the essential
features that decentralized architecture
use case iot smart farming
use case smart farming iot design this
use case addresses the design
formalities using iot iot design is an
essential part of the navigational
ecosystem smart farming requires precise
architecture and components that help
bring benefits to the farmers the
various factors that determine the iot
design are data cost efficiency and
product quality the efficiency and
durability of the ecosystem help the
farmers plan their harvest and so based
on the climatic conditions using the
sensors and geospatial location data so
be precise any farmer needs to
understand the fundamental design that
can help run the ecosystem smart farming
is useful as it helps the farmer to
predict conditions and sow crops with
less cost and utilize automation
capabilities to have such systems you
need to purchase the right hardware
which can monitor the accuracy of data
and quality of the sensor once you have
these systems you can benefit more from
farming there are four things you need
to integrate for smart farming first is
a data engine smart farming should have
a robust data processing engine that can
act as the brain and handle data
processing storage and lead to efficient
output
the second is hardware you need to
ensure that the hardware is durable and
easy to maintain hardware or self-fixing
algorithms is even better
the third aspect is mobile access this
is possible using a smartphone along
with offline or online mobile
applications
to enable all three processes you need
cloud infrastructure with the edge layer
this iot system can enable smart farming
for any crops in any geographical
location let us look at another use case
on using sim cards to monitor sugar
level in a diabetic patient diabetes
management is a recurring concept where
the patient has to check the blood sugar
at regular intervals in the traditional
way he has to go to the physician lab or
he has to have his home blood glucose
monitoring system iot can help create a
system with the blood glucose data will
be transmitted remotely via smartphone
and a sim embedded in it
identifying the necessary and right
hardware is one of the crucial steps of
creating such a system you need to
choose the sensors for your device or
create a custom one which fits the
glucometer this can be a sim card the
next step is to ensure that the quality
of your sensors is good and has seamless
integration with the system finally make
sure that the data monitoring happens in
real time with high accuracy now when
the hardware landscape of this ecosystem
is ready you need to set the software
then first it is crucial that you have
software with self-repair algorithm for
service management to enable this
process you need cloud infrastructure
with edge and finally a smartphone to
work with the devices and sensors
key takeaways now that you have
completed this lesson you should be able
to explain iot reference architectures
and frameworks describe the iot
interoperability and its design
considerations and finally discuss
industry aligned use cases
here's a list of iot projects for 2020.
first up is smart mirror smart mirrors
are a very cool iot application
these mirrors can be used to display
temperature news
weather calendar clock and complements
on the screen
apart from these smart mirrors can be
used to click the perfect selfies with a
built-in camera it can also be installed
with speakers to play some music and
they also provide on-demand workout
sessions with world-class trainers
the mirror can be used to browse the
internet make phone calls and even be
connected with other devices for
collaboration
next up is smart money transfer we're
heading towards complete digitization
transactions are made possible on your
cell phone with apps like apple pay
google pay and paypal
but imagine if you could walk to a store
and pay with the wrist watch wouldn't
that be cool the purpose of the smart
wallet is to provide an easy and
reliable platform for money transactions
it is compact variable and rechargeable
for safety purposes the user
authenticity is validated the smart
money transfer technology can reduce the
burden of mobile money transfer when
you're on the go you could easily step
into a store purchase the goods and pay
hassle free after every successful
transaction the balance is updated
immediately to avoid any uncertainty
next up is iot based smart arm
now this project includes the creation
of a robotic arm which can pick and
place things from one place to another
to control this action the robotic arm
can be moved using specific commands
some advanced arms allow the user to
change the end effect of the arm to
perform various different actions it can
be used to make art print 3d images and
build production lines
it can also be used to perform your
day-to-day chores at number 4 we have
smart irrigation
now with changing climate and recurrent
water crisis
farmers suffer a great deal with growing
crops smart irrigation puts an end to
this ordeal
this system comes with the moisture
sensor that checks the soil for its
water content when the soil moisture
drops below a certain value the system
triggers the water supply at number five
we have smart door now as the name
suggests this project aims at creating
smart doors that control the entry and
exit of humans
these doors open and close automatically
when you pass by the door can also be
controlled remotely you could unlock the
door for a friend by tapping an icon on
your smartphone
once they exit you're immediately
notified the owner can also choose who
has the access to the door at number six
we have air monitoring system now air
monitoring has become crucial for the
environment and what better way to do it
than incorporating iot
the iot system uses air sensors to sense
the presence of harmful gases or
compounds in the air
the data collected can be used by the
local authorities to make a detailed
analysis
necessary actions can also be taken to
ensure that the air quality levels don't
reach an extreme low especially in areas
with hospitals and schools
moving on to number seven we have smart
alarm clock now there are many
variations of a smart alarm clock but
the alarm we are talking about is a self
setting alarm the smart alarm clock uses
your google calendar to check your
appointments to set the alarm it can
also procure data from gps about your
eta to a particular place and consider
the weather to automatically adjust your
wake time
all of this is just making life more
easier moving on at number eight we have
iot based weather reporting system
now the system deals with monitoring
weather and climate changes like
humidity temperature moisture wind speed
uv radiation light intensity and even
carbon monoxide levels in the air using
multiple sensors now these installed
sensors send data to the web page that
is plotted as graphical statistics
the project even consists of an
application that sends notifications as
an effective alert to warn people about
sudden and drastic weather changes
so when you're heading out the app could
easily tell you what the weather will be
like and suggest carrying an umbrella or
perhaps a sunblock
at number 9 we have smart wheelchair
there are over 132 million wheelchair
users across the globe smart wheelchairs
is an excellent innovation
typically it comes with built-in sensors
on the seats that collect data every
second
the data provides insight into the
seating behavior of the patient and the
energy required to maintain the posture
other variations of smart wheelchairs
could include fall detection
these features allow people to monitor
the patient from a remote location
and finally at number 10 we have smart
street light system
this iot based street light monitoring
system not only monitors but also
ensures low power consumption and
detects faulty lights
the street lights have external sensing
that automatically turns on at the
desired intensity based on the lighting
needed
control of light intensity is based on
the movement of people or vehicles
in case of an emergency the lights
increase the brightness to maximum
intensity thereby ensuring safety
when deployed as a part of a smart city
the users can be informed about any
outages
they can also register a complaint for
immediate service in this video we will
learn about arduino
the arduino platform has grown in
popularity among those just getting
started with electronics and for good
purpose
in contrast to the majority of earlier
programmable circuit boards to load new
code onto the arduino you don't need a
separate piece of hardware all you just
need is a usb
cable let's see what's in it for you in
this session
we'll first start with understanding
what is arduino
followed by which we will see why to use
arduino then we will look at some of the
important features of arduino
after that we will see the different
types of arduino boards
and at last we will see advantages and
disadvantages of arduino but before we
begin make sure you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and clicked on the
bell icon so you never miss an update
from simply that so without any further
ado let's get started
what is arduino
arduino is an open source electronic
gadget that treats input such as light
on a sensor a finger on a button or a
tweet and generates output based on
those inputs such as turning on an led
or activating a motor
arduino was created at the design
institute as a simple tool for students
with no clear experience with
electronics or programming
arduino boards are microcontrollers not
entire computers with operating system
of their own like the raspberry pi
arduino just run c or c plus plus code
that is stored in the firmware
the arduino ide is free software that
allows you to create and upload code on
an arduino board
why arduino
arduino has been used in millions of
projects and applications due to its
simple and accessible user interface
the arduino software is simple to use
for beginners
but it is customizable for advanced
users
it works on mac windows and linux
systems
arduino is a valuable tool for learning
new skills anyone including youngsters
amateurs artists and programmers can
begin tinkering by simply following the
step-by-step instructions
it can be used by teachers and students
to create low-cost scientific equipments
to demonstrate chemistry and physics
principles and to begin learning
programming and robotics
designers and architects create
interactive prototypes while musicians
and artists create installations and try
out new instruments
features of arduino
arduino has microcontroller of atmega328
and the operating voltage is 5 volts
whereas the input voltage is recommended
to be from 7 to 12 volts and input
voltage limits from 6 to 20 volts
we have digital input output pins that
is we have 14 pins
and we have analog input six pins
and we have dc current per input output
pin 40 milliampere
and dc current for 3.3 volt pen is 50
milliamperes and we have flash memory of
32 kilobytes
and we have sram of 2 kb
and eep rom of 1 kb
and we have clock speed of 16 megahertz
now let us look at the different types
of arduino boards present
firstly we have arduino uno
arduino uno includes everything you will
need to get started it has 14 digital
input output pins 6 analog input a usb
port a power jack and a reset button
among other features it comes with
everything you will need to get started
with the microcontroller plug into a
computer with usb cable or power it with
an ac to dc adapter or battery
next we have lilypad arduino lillypad is
variable e-textile device created by lee
and designed in collaboration with
sparkfun each lily pad was cleverly
constructed with large connection pads
and a flat back to sew conductive thread
into garments
in addition the daily pad features its
own set of input output power and sensor
boards designed exclusively for e-text
styles and can even be washed
arduino mega the arduino mega is the
larger brother of arduino uno it
contains many digital input output pins
that is 54
and 16 analog inputs a usb connection a
power jack and a reset button it comes
with everything you will need to get
started with microcontroller plug it
into a computer with usb cable or power
it with ac to dc adapter or a battery
redboot arduino
the arduino ide can program the red
board over the use of mini-b connector
it will run on windows 8 without
requiring changes to your security
settings
because of the usb chip we used it's
more sturdy and it's fully flat on the
back making it easier to integrate into
your projects
and we have arduino leonardo
the leonardo is arduino's initial
development board with a single
microcontroller and usb port
as a result it may be less expensive and
easier additionally because the board
handles usb directly code libraries are
available that allow the board to
imitate a computer keyboard mouse and
other components
now let us look at the advantages of
arduino
in comparison to the other
microcontroller system arduino boards
are comparatively affordable the
arduino's module its cheapest version
can be assembled by hand and even
pre-made arduino module cost less than
50 dollars
for windows macintosh os x and linux
the arduino software ide is provided the
vast majority of microcontroller systems
are windows only compatible
the arduino software is simple for
beginners but it's also flexible enough
for advanced users
for experienced programmers the arduino
software is available as an open source
tool to extend
people who want to learn more about the
language can use c plus plus libraries
and those who want to learn more about
technicals specifics can switch from
arduino to avrc programming language
the arduino is an open source and has
hardware that can be expanded the
arduino board blueprints are made
available under creative common license
allowing experienced circuits designers
to create their module version extending
and upgrading it
at last we will look at the
disadvantages of arduino
arduino cannot run multiple programs at
a time
no memory safety checks expensive for
cpu power and memory
it has lack of built-in communications
lack of built-in peripherals
the limited number of programming
languages
and a limited number of ides
in this video we will discuss about
raspberry pi
the raspberry pi foundation developed a
series of small single board computers
in the united kingdom so let's look at
today's agenda
we'll first discuss what is raspberry pi
then we will see some of the raspberry
pi use cases
followed by which we will see the
different types of raspberry pi boards
available
proceeding further we will see the
applications of raspberry pi and lastly
we will see the advantages and
disadvantages of raspberry pi but before
we begin make sure you have subscribed
to our youtube channel and clicked on
the bell icon so you never miss an
update from simply learn so without
wasting any further time let's get
started with what is raspberry pi
the raspberry pi is a small low cost
computer the size of a credit card that
connects to a computer monitor or
television and utilizes a conventional
keyboard and mouse
raspberry pi can do everything a desktop
computer does including accessing the
internet
using raspberry pi we can watch high
definition videos access spreadsheets
word processing and play games
the raspberry pi can communicate with
the outside world and has been used in
variety of digital maker projects
raspberry pi is also used in music
machines and parent detectors as well as
weather stations and tweeting bird
houses with infrared cameras
raspberry pi use cases
raspberry pi is using computer desktop
a simple desktop can be built using a
raspberry pi a micro sd card and a power
source an hdmi cable and a suitable
display such as an old monitor are also
required you will also need a usb
keyboard and a mouse
robotics controller there are numerous
raspberry pi robot controller projects a
specific robotics package for pi is
available which is powered by the device
battery and can be used to interface
with and control robots
printing using a raspberry pi with the
raspberry pi we can print anything all
we need is raspberry pi that's connected
to your home network as well as some
print server software this is
accomplished by first installing the
samba file sharing program then cups
cup stands for common unix printing
system includes printed drivers as well
as management console
game server
the basic operating system for raspberry
pi has a special version of mini craft
game pre-installed the raspberry pi
applications can be used as a game
server
it's fantastic mini craft game server a
wonderful gaming experience can be
created by using many raspberry pi
game machine
as a retro gaming machine the raspberry
pi is perfect
it is one of the machine's lightest
components the raspberry pi zero in
particular is a variant that can fit
into small locations and be used for
gaming projects the raspberry pi may
also be used to restore many popular
16-bit game systems
now let us look at the types of
raspberry pi
the different types of raspberry pi are
raspberry pi model b
raspberry pi model a
raspberry pi model b plus raspberry pi
model a plus raspberry pi zero raspberry
pi 2 raspberry pi 3 model b
and raspberry pi 0w
the different applications of raspberry
pi are it is used as media streamer
tablet computer internet radio
home automation
robotics command
arcade devices
cosmic computer and different raspberry
pi projects
now let us look at the advantages of
raspberry pi
raspberry pi is about the size of a
credit card
the raspberry pi is inexpensive
using raspberry pi to function as a
server is more efficient than using a
regular server
the raspberry pi is ideal for adaptive
technology because it can display
visuals as well as play movies
the micro computer can be used by small
businesses on a tight budget to use
their product or build new technology
that integrates the product
now let us look at the disadvantages of
raspberry pi
raspberry pi is not a computer
replacement and the processor is not as
fast downloading and installing software
takes time
so you won't be able to do any intricate
multitasking
other operating systems such as windows
are incompatible
this product will not be beneficial for
large-scale businesses that already have
large servers which can perform all the
tasks that raspberry pi can
as a result it would not be worth it and
putting everything together it would
take time in this video we will see
arduino versus raspberry pi
let us look at today's agenda we'll
first start with understanding what is
arduino
after that we will look at what is
raspberry pi
then we will see a comparison between
arduino versus raspberry pi on the
following parameters
control unit
architecture
specifications
operating system licensing applications
and types of boards and at last we will
see which is better arduino or raspberry
pi
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click on the bell icon so you never miss
an update from simply learn so without
wasting any further time let's get
started
what is arduino
arduino is an open source electronic
gadget that reads inputs such as light
on a sensor a finger on a button or a
tweet and generates output based on
those inputs such as turning on the led
or activating a motor
arduino was created at a design
institute as a simple tool for students
with no prior experience with
electronics and programming
arduino boards are microcontrollers not
entire computers with operating systems
of their own like the raspberry pi
arduino just run c c plus plus code that
is stored in the firmware
the arduino ide integrated development
environment is free software that allows
you to create and upload code to an
arduino board
now let us see what is raspberry pi
raspberry pi is small low cost computer
the size of a credit card that connects
to a computer monitor or television and
utilizes a conventional keyboard and a
mouse
raspberry pi can do everything a desktop
computer does including accessing the
internet
using raspberry pi we can watch high
definition videos access spreadsheets
word processing and play games
raspberry pi has a dedicated processor
memory and a graphics driver just like a
pc it also comes with its own operating
system raspberry pi operating system
which is a modified version of linux
raspberry pi is also used in music
machines parent detectors as well as
weather stations and tweeting bird
houses with infrared cameras
let us look at the comparison between
arduino versus raspberry pi first let us
look at the control unit
arduino is a member of atmega family of
microcontrollers
a microcontroller chip common on arduino
uno boats is atmega328
the 8-bit avr microcontroller family
includes atmega328 microcontrollers
a surface mount at mega chip is seen on
some arduino uno boards
the raspberry pi is an arm controller
unit
broadcom chips based on arms cortex a
application processor have powered
raspberry pi from its release
the raspberry pi 3 is the latest version
of the raspberry pi launched in february
2016.
it has 1.2 gigahertz amp cortex a53 cpu
making it compatible for the arm 63.
it has 1.2 gigahertz arm cortex a53 cpu
making it compatible for the arm 64
architecture
architecture
the harvard architecture is used by
arduino cpu which means that the program
code and the program data have distinct
memory
it is made up of two types of memories
program memory and data memory
the data is saved in the data memory
while the code is kept in the flash
program memory
whereas in raspberry pi raspberry pi
contains a single core arm v6 processor
running at 700 megahertz a video core
force gpu and 512 mb of ram
its operating system and data are stored
on sd card
raspbian a lightweight linux operating
system based on debian is officially
supported by the raspberry pi
licensing
arduino is an open source electronics
platform that uses simple hardware and
software to make it easy to use
it's for everyone who wants to make
interactive projects arduino perceives
the environment by receiving data from a
variety of sensors and actuators to
influence its surroundings
raspberry pi's hardware and software are
both proprietary raspberry pi has never
claimed to be open source
many aspects of it particularly the
software are open source but not all of
it is
the raspberry pi has been criticized for
having closed source components
operating system
arduino boards are single board
microcontrollers with firmware and no
operating system
a firmware program is a piece of
software that is installed on hardware
device
it doesn't have an operating system but
it does have a firmware which can be
programmed using several ides including
the arduino ide
raspberry pi operating system for pc and
mac is dbn with raspberry pi desktop
it installs the raspberry pi operating
system desktop on pc or apple mac as
well as most of the recommended software
that comes with raspberry pi operating
system
now let us look at the specifications
so we look at the specifications between
arduino uno r3 and raspberry pi 3 model
b plus
so if we look at the system arduino has
microcontroller system whereas raspberry
pi has single boarded computer processor
arduino has avr at mega 328p
and raspberry pi has
ram
in arduino uno we have ram of 2 kb
whereas in raspberry pi model 3 b plus
we have 1gb ram
clock speed 16 megahertz in arduino and
1.4 gigahertz in raspberry pi
execution in arduino single program can
be executed at a time
whereas in raspberry pi multiple
programs can run at a time
current current is 5 milli ampere in
both arduino and raspberry pi and gpu io
pins arduino has 20 and raspberry pi has
40.
and power consumption in arduino is 175
milli watt and in raspberry pi it is 700
milliwatt
applications
arduino is used in waving machines
traffic light countdown timer parking
lot counter embedded systems home
automation industrial automation medical
instrument and emergency light for
railways
whereas raspberry pi is used in desktop
pc wireless usage game servers retro
gaming machine robot controller stop
motion camera and time lapse camera
now let us look at the different types
of arduino and raspberry pi in the
arduino we have arduino uno
lillypad arduino arduino mega arduino
leonardo
arduino red board and arduino shields
whereas in raspberry pi
we have raspberry pi 1 model b raspberry
pi 1 model a
model b plus model a plus
then we have raspberry pi 0 raspberry pi
2 raspberry pi 0w and raspberry pi 3
model p
and we know a raspberry pi which is
better the arduino and raspberry pi have
their own set of benefits and drawbacks
the best option for you will be
determined by the requirement of your
project and your budget
arduino is ideal for automating
repetitive operations such as opening
and closing doors turning on and off
lights and so on
arduino should be the first pick if your
project has any repeating elements and
just requires generating output
depending on sensory inputs
raspberry pi is ideally suited for
complex activities such as controlling
complex robots weather monitoring and
internet publishing among others
if your project necessitates advanced
functionality as well as internet access
then the raspberry pi is the option we
will be learning about the top arduino
projects for 2022 but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies so if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session so we will get started by
understanding what exactly is arduino
and followed by that we will get started
with top arduino projects for 2022
and once we are done with the top
arduino projects we will understand the
fundamental differences between arduino
and raspberry pi i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now without
further ado let's get started with our
first topic that is what exactly is
arduino all to our experts in this video
we will be discussing about arduino
projects the different domains where
arduino can be used and how
let's look at today's agenda
we'll first look at locking projects
using arduino then we will look at some
of the rover projects using arduino
game projects using arduino then
automation projects using arduino
followed by which will look at robotics
projects and help projects
then we will look at some of the drone
projects audio projects iot projects and
lastly we will look at sensor projects
using arduino
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell like so you never
miss an update from simpler
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
locking projects using arduino
frequently we need to secure a space in
our home or business so that no one can
enter without our permission and our
valuable accessories and assets are
protected from theft or loss
there are many different types of
security systems available today
but they all rely on fingerprints retina
scanners iris scanners face id tongue
scanners rfid readers password pins
patterns and other biometrics for
authentication
the most cost effective solution is to
utilize an arduino-based password or pin
based system
some of the locking projects using
arduino are arduino door lock system
rfid and keyboard lock system
we have unlocked door with knock system
push button lock system and gesture
control lock using arduino
then we have rover projects using
arduino
the arduino robot is the world's first
arduino powered vehicle
on each of robot's two boards there are
two cpus the motor board is in charge of
the motors while the control board is in
charge of reading sensors and deciding
how to run them
each board is a complete arduino board
that can be programmed using arduino ide
using arduino we can create many rover
projects like voice control rover
line follower rover
gesture control rover
survey rover
ir remote control rover
and similarly
we have autonomous rover and many more
game projects using arduino
some remarkable arduino based game
projects ranging from retro gaming
played on a little screen to more
sophisticated projects requiring some
assembly some of the arduino gaming
projects are
snake game
then we have chess game
pinball
spaceship simulator
and claw machine
automation projects using arduino
the robust characteristics of arduino
are well suited to a popular section of
applications that is automation the
arduino board can be used to create a
wide variety of automation applications
automation has brought convenience to
whole new level from controlling room
lights with your smartphone to
automatically organizing events instead
of using mechanical switches you can now
operate all of your home electronics
from the palm of your hand
some of the automation projects using
arduino are
home automation and sanitizer dispenser
automated shower boiler
automatic motion sensor trash
and ir remote controller home appliances
health projects using arduino
any medical equipment that has internet
connectivity and can measure one or more
health data of a patient who is
connected to the device such as
heartbeat body temperature blood
pressure ecg steps etc is referred to as
arduino based patient health monitoring
system
if there is a rapid change in patients
health the equipment can record and
transmit the data
iot encompasses everything from smart
watches to fitness tracker to hospital
equipment that can link to the internet
arduino based health projects are being
developed to create new medical gadgets
it may be used to measure body factors
such as ecg temperature moisture and
heartbeat it also identifies the
patient's physical state and location
some of the health projects using
arduino are
smart bridge band smart bioware
portable ecg
ultrasonic site
and smart health kit
road projects using arduino
drone are airborne vehicles that range
in size from micro to multi-rotor
quadcopters a camera is sometimes
included with a drone allowing the users
to watch and record the bird's eye
perspective a drone is made up of
numerous parts one of the most
significant of which is the flight
controller which acts as the drone's
brain
the arduino development board is great
for this purpose especially because
there are variety of models available
ranging from the tiny arduino nano to
arduino mega all of which are small
enough to fit into the design of a drone
some of the drone projects using arduino
are
quadcopter
autopilot drone
mind control drone
kite power drone
and hover craft
robotics project using arduino
we can learn about electronics mechanics
and software using the arduino robotics
project it includes a number of project
examples that you can easily copy as
well as robust robotics platform that
you may have to execute a variety of
jobs
some of the robotics projects are
robotic arm
drawing robot
fighter robot ball tracking robot and
spider robot
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
audio projects using arduino
if you enjoy working with both hardware
and software arduino is the perfect
hobby for you arduino is a programmable
logical controller that can do a variety
of cool things depending on your
programming skills
using the arduino to make music is a
special genre of projects
if you will some are straightforward to
implement while others are more
difficult
so some of the arduino projects for
audio are
paper piano with arduino
vfo or rf generator
arduino mp3 player
arduino uno guitar pedal an arduino bit
detector and we even have mini vintage
internet radio mosfet communication
using arduino and many more
iot projects using arduino
arduino iot cloud is a tool that allows
creators to create connected products
quickly easily and securely multiple
devices can be linked together and data
can be exchanged in real time you can
also keep an eye on them using a simple
user interface from anywhere
some of the iot or bluetooth projects
using arduino are
iot bicycle radar iot pet feeder
telegram bot
arduino bluetooth camera and smart
parking system
sensor projects using arduino
one of the aspects that make an arduino
so valuable is the simplicity with which
it can retrieve sensor information
sensors are devices that transform a
physical quantity into an electrical
quantity such as light intensity or
temperature
the different types of sensors that are
available are
light sensor motion sensor temperature
sensor magnetic field sensor gravity
sensor humidity sensor
moisture vibration and pressure sensor
electrical field sensor sound sensor and
position sensor
manufacturing machinery aircraft
vehicles medicine and robotics are just
few of the use cases of these sensors
so the different sensor projects that
can be made using arduino are
temperature monitoring
smoke detection using gas sensor
3d scanner
smart plant incubator
and water quality monitoring system
in this video we will be discussing
about raspberry pi projects
the raspberry pi has a wide range of
uses
the microcomputer has grown to
accomplish many odd activities in
addition to many standard tasks
raspberry pi was created with the intent
of allowing people to play with the
circuit board and to aid in the
development of new computing skills
the internet is huge amount of
information about the raspberry pi's
various applications and projects
as well as recommendations on how to
execute them
we will go over a few projects that
demonstrate the microcomputer's wide
range of capabilities
this video will show you the most
popular and useful projects
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply now
so without any further ado let's get
started
the first project is web server
the raspberry pi serves as a web server
for multiple users
there are numerous web server packages
to choose from however in the most
circumstances the raspberry pi's
performance is insufficient for reliably
hosting large amount of dynamic online
content
instead the mini computer is
significantly better suited for local
testing environment simple static
websites with low visitor accounts on
the other hand might be hosted on
raspberry pi server
scanner server
setting up your raspberry pi as a
scanner server using same is a terrific
way to bring your old scanner up to date
instead of purchasing a wi-fi capable
scanner you can use a device like
raspberry pi 0 to provide that
capabilities scanner access now easy is
the acronym for same this program serves
as a standardized method of gaining
access to the scanners
xbox cloud gaming on raspberry pi
microsoft's xbox cloud gaming service
allows you to stream various video games
from their servers to another device
in this project we will be streaming
these games from the xbox cloud gaming
service to the raspberry pi
using the chromium web browser you can
broadcast xbox cloud gaming to your
raspberry pi in a reasonably simple
manner
this project will even show you how to
turn your raspberry pi into pure xbox
cloud gaming machine
the xbox cloud gaming service isn't the
only game streaming option for your
raspberry pi you can also broadcast
games to use pi using google's gaming
service
game console
we can turn your raspberry pi into a
retro gaming console also we can now
simulate practically any classic game
from 1970s to the 1990s using this
little computer
retropie a piece of software that solves
all of your emulation needs is now
available it's simple piece of software
to set up and it also offers a user
friendly interface
you may now play old games with retropie
you can use any raspberry pi model for
this project however the raspberry pi 4
model such as the raspberry pi model 4b
that is 4gb is strongly recommended
remote control 3d printer
octoprint which is one of the most well
known 3d printing program can also be
used on raspberry pi this software lets
you collect statistics and even monitor
your 3d printer from afar
this software lets you collect
statistics and even monitor your 3d
printer from afar
you can now control your 3d printer
remotely rather than using an sd card
aside from that you can connect a webcam
to a 3d printer to monitor the progress
of your printing
you will need a wi-fi adapter like the
model tl
wn725n to make your 3d printer work
because you will need to connect it to
the internet
language translator
this project necessitates some coding
and programming experience
we can utilize the google translate
library or any other python translating
tool to make this project much easier
you will need to know how to set up text
to speech speech recognition translation
apis and so on because this project has
many layers
overall it's still a worthwhile project
that you can do with your raspberry pi
and add to your achievements of
raspberry pi projects
security camera
you may have observed that different
raspberry pi models are compatible with
different camera modules
the raspberry pi 8 megapixel camera
module for example is only compatible
with raspberry pi 1 2 and 3 versions
you may now make your own security
camera for your home with this camera
model another advantage of this project
is that you can add whatever other
features you like
for example we can access video feeds
from afar and have them immediately
uploaded to a server for backup
a number of package or library
prerequisites are already available on
the internet on your raspberry pi you
can simply download or alter it
wi-fi extender
a wi-fi extender is another simple
project it's a low cost and effective
solution to increase wifi range
if you have a bad wifi signal in your
garden or even your room you may utilize
your raspberry pi to boost your signal
it's an excellent substitute for
commercial wi-fi repeater furthermore
because this is a diy project you can
always alter it and add new features
because this job has already been
completed by many people you can just
search the internet for the finest and
most convenient way to complete it
running android tv on raspberry pi
android tv is specialized version of
google's famous mobile operating system
it has a revised interface that better
accommodates the horizontal nature of
television screens
because the operating system is better
suited to white horizontal screens and
remote controls it's the best option for
connecting the pi to your tv the google
play store also gives you access to many
downloadable apps
the most significant difficulty with
running android tv on the raspberry pi
right now is that builds lack hardware
video decoding and encoding capabilities
the pi 4 mod will be pi 400 and the
compute module 4 are the only devices
that can run android tv
running zoom on the raspberry pi
we can utilize the feature to set up
meetings so that people can readily
connect with you
the individual hosting the meeting on
the other hand will need their own zoom
account
the person who creates a meeting has the
authority to determine who is allowed to
speak and share resources such as the
computer screen
with the free plan you can connect up to
100 additional individuals for total of
40 minutes because the raspberry pi does
not contain any arm binaries it is
difficult to run zoom on it
we will use a handy piece of software
called box 86 to get around this
box 86 is an emulation program that
transforms
86 instructions to arm instruction set
which the raspberry pi recognizes
raspberry pi bluetooth speakers
you may greatly expand the capabilities
of your raspberry pi by connecting it to
a set of speakers
this project gives you the opportunity
to stream audio directly to any vintage
speakers or hi-fi system making them
more modern
we can add support for apple airplay
spotify connect and synchronize multiple
room audio to raspberry pi in addition
to bluetooth audio
we are going to utilize a balina image
named balinas sound to bring all of this
extra capabilities to our raspberry pi
this instruction from balina greatly
simplifies the setup process and should
lessen the chances of making mistakes
home assistant using raspberry pi
home assistant is an open source home
automation program that was created
using raspberry pi based device the
software was created with the goal of
protecting your privacy and retaining
control in the hands of the user
you can monitor the status of all of
your devices in your house with the home
assistant you can even automate your
interactions with them
we can program home assistant to turn on
all of the lights automatically when it
gets dark and you're at home when you
cast a movie on your chromecast you can
even program it to dim the lights in
your living room
raspberry pi is an excellent platform
for home automation it's compact
inexpensive has many networking
functions and consumes little power
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
minecraft using raspberry pi
for this project we need to install a
custom version of minecraft designed
just for raspberry pi minecraft pi
edition is a name of this version of
minecraft
this version of minecraft is much older
than the current version it does however
have an advantage it is entirely free
additionally this version of minecraft
includes a python library for
interacting with the game environment
in this video we will discuss about a
particular type of raspberry pi that is
raspberry pi zero see what's in it for
you in this session we'll first start
with understanding what is raspberry pi
followed by we will see some of the
features of raspberry pi 0 and
specifications of raspberry pi 0.
then we will see applications
and the difference between raspberry pi
0 and raspberry pi 0w
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click down the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
the raspberry pi zero
the raspberry pi zero is a super cheap
super compact computer
the zero is smaller than a credit card
measuring 65 millimeter by 30 millimeter
and is only five millimeter thick
it also weights nine grams the raspberry
pi zero is inexpensive costing only four
to five dollars
the raspberry pi zero w is member of the
pi zero family with wireless lan and
bluetooth capabilities
the raspberry pi zero uses the same
single core broadcom cpu as the original
raspberry pi however it has been turned
to 1 gigahertz making it 40 percent
faster than the original
when you consider the zero raspberry pi
with 512 mb of ram it's around three
times faster than the original raspberry
pi in terms of total performance
features of raspberry pi zero
the raspberry pi zero has a single tiny
hdmi port rather than the full hdmi port
found on prior raspberry pi devices
despite this it can still produce video
at
1080p and 60 frames per second
one micro usb port provides power to the
raspberry pi zero while the other serves
as the usb outboard for connecting a
keyboard mouse wi-fi dongle or other
peripheral
there is no standard wi-fi or ethernet
port on the raspberry pi zero you will
have to figure out how to connect to the
internet on your own
but that's the kind of purpose of this
bare bones gadget
it has an unpopulated 40 pin gpio header
and an unpopulated composite video
header just as all other raspberry pi
variants you can use this to solder on
your own interface components if you
like
which is where the raspberry pi's
enormous potential and flexibility
really shy
another important cost cutting technique
is the lack of fixed storage on
raspberry pi zero instead you will need
to provide your own storage in the form
of micro sd card which you may place
into the provided slot
the raspberry pi 0 like previous
raspberry pi devices runs on raspbian
its lightweight operating system based
on the dbn operating system open source
project
being free to download raspberry and
also gives users access to pi shop which
is essentially an app store with
hundreds of packages built particularly
for the raspberry pi given the raspberry
pi zeros capable hardware it can just
run about any packages
now let us look at the applications of
raspberry pi the raspberry pi 0 is
already a computer that can be used as a
desktop pc or notebook without the need
for a screen or keyboard some of the
applications are it is used to make a
wildlife camera
this is the droid you are looking for
build a portable pocket sized computer
a compact raspberry pi zero server
binary clock with unique unicon p hat
zero board raspberry pi zero fpv robot
remote control smart drone
raspberry pi zero wi-fi security camera
portable game console
home network music system google home
with bluetooth speaker and many more
specifications of raspberry pi 0.
some of the specifications of raspberry
pi zero are it has eight zero two point
one one
byteless land
bluetooth of four point one bluetooth
low energy and one gigahertz single core
cpu five 12 mb of ram
mini hdmi port and micro usb otg port
micro usb power
hat compatible 40 pin header composite
video and reset headers and csi camera
connectors
now let us look at the difference
between raspberry pi 0 and raspberry pi
0w
the w in raspberry pi 0
stands for wireless and it denotes the
pi 0 model's wireless functionality that
is the most significant distinction
between the two models
while the raspberry pi 0 was designed to
deliver more functionality while being
half the size of a plus board
later the raspberry pi 0w was released
with built-in wireless connectivity
eliminating the need for a separate
accessory or module to enable bluetooth
and wi-fi
the raspberry pi zero is five dollars
whereas the raspberry pi zero w is
roughly ten dollars the price will of
course vary depending on its
availability and location
the main distinction between two is this
with the rest of specification staying
the same in this video we will discuss
about raspberry pi 4.
let's see what's in it for you in
today's session
we'll first start with understanding
what is raspberry pi 4
then we will look at some of its
features
and specifications and lastly we will
see the applications of raspberry pi
phone but before we begin make sure you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and click down the bell like so you
never miss an update from simply learn
what is raspberry pi 4
the raspberry pi 4 model b which is a
1.5 gigahertz 64-bit quad-core arm
cortex a72 processor which was released
in june 2019
when utilized with an adequate power
supply the pi 4 can be also be powered
using a usb c connector allowing for
more power to be delivered to downstream
peripherals
raspberry pi 4 can do everything a
desktop computer does including
accessing the internet and watching high
definition videos as well as
spreadsheets word processing and game
the raspberry pi 4 is capable of
handling a wide range of tasks including
reading articles like watching videos
and working with the
text features of raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi 4 has improved speed and
performance over previous generations we
have created a complete desktop
experience for the first time whether
you are editing documents browsing the
web with multiple tab opens wrangling
spreadsheets or creating a presentation
the experience will be smooth and
familiar
multiple usb ports the usb ports on your
raspberry pi 4 has been upgraded in
addition to the two usb connection there
are
two usb3 ports which can transport data
up to 10 times quicker
quick networking
gigabit ethernet interconnected wireless
networking and bluetooth are included
with the raspberry pi 4.
silent and energy saving the raspberry
pi is fan less energy efficient computer
that works quietly and consumes
significantly less electricity than
traditional pcs
ram selection depending on how much ram
you need raspberry pi offers multiple
variants 1gb 2gb 4gb and 8gb ram
now let us look at the specifications of
raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi has broadcom quad-core
cortex a72 arm version 864-bit processor
it has 1gb 2gb 4gb or 8gb sd
ram it has 2.4 gigahertz and 5.0
gigahertz i triple e wireless bluetooth
of 5.0
it has gigabit ethernet two usb 3.0
ports and two usb 2.0 ports raspberry pi
standard 40 pin gpio header
two micro hdmi ports two lan mipi dsi
display port
two lan csi camera port
4 pole stereo audio and composite video
port
micro sd slot for loading os and data
storage
5 volt dc usb c connector and 5vdc gpio
header
and power over ethernet is enabled and
lastly operating temperature is between
0 to 50 degree celsius
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
let us look at some of the applications
of raspberry pi 4.
raspberry pi 4 is used for portable gape
console
home network music system
google home with bluetooth speaker
raspberry pi food security system
social media bought using raspberry pi
4.
then we have raspberry pi based retro
gaming system
machine learning on raspberry pi 4
raspberry pi 4 wi-fi security camera
remote control smart drone portable
pocket size computer now with that we
have come to an end of this session on
the iot full course if you have any
queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you
require the resources that we used in
this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you